so i want to talk about monogamy and
male psychology you say that uh
monogamous marriage norms constrain the
darker aspects of male psychology talk
me through that
well i am
do i say darker i hope i don't say
darker um that was that's my uh okay
summary
so uh
yeah so the idea is is that um because
of the differences in male and female
biology human males can benefit from
multiple matings and there's nothing
about a pair bonding instinct so
gorillas have a pair bonding instinct
that prevents you from having multiple
pair bonds and this is true of men and
women except men can benefit uh because
they can you can think of
serial versus parallel so men can have
babies with multiple women at the same
time whereas women can only have one
baby at a time right and so there's few
there's less benefit for a woman having
multiple husbands than a man having
multiple wives and polygeny turns out to
be pretty common across human society so
in the largest anthropological database
that we have 85 percent of human
societies allow elite and high status
men to take additional wives
what was how was that study conducted
like who was the sample size
well so back in the 1950s
anthropologists began putting together a
database called the ethnographic atlas
um which contains over 1200 different
societies so it's it's you know in their
societies from all different continents
basically all the places where
anthropologists had collected data and
that was elite and high status males
were permitted to take more than one
partner yeah but even if you look at
hunter-gatherer society so 90 of
hunter-gatherer societies allow
uh prestigious men to take additional
wives and they don't typically take many
but they might have two or three you
know very rarely do you see more than
four wives in hunter-gatherers
why do you think that is just
difficulties for the male to support
more than four yeah yeah and so and and
the societies that do have monogamous
marriage uh it's typically because the
men are too similar right so there's no
benefit to oh if there's a hierarchy
yeah so if the men are more or less the
same because of the nature of the
economy then then then pollution doesn't
appear
is pillaging just uh more efficient
resource allocation then
well i mean
that's what that's what uh evolutionary
biologists have argued that if you give
females the choice and there's high
inequality among men say in wealth it
would be fitness maximizing for them to
allocate according to the available
resources so if you have a choice
between being the second wife of a guy
who's three times richer then you're
their number two choice
then that's an easy choice um i mean
there's things with paternal investment
and stuff because you know there's only
one male and it can only do so much
paternal investment but if resources are
the critical thing having enough food
say then then that logic makes sense but
what it does do is that it'll inevitably
create a pool of low status unmarried
men if there's too much polygeny uh and
those are the guys who cause problems
because they're faced with possibly
being zeros in the evolutionary race and
so they are willing to take big risks in
order to catapult themselves up the
status hierarchy and have a chance to
get into the marriage and mating market
are there any examples from history of
times where there's been
large swaths of
sexless men at the bottom of this
underclass
yeah it appears lots of times um
uh i mean the places that we know best
ethnographically are in these
geruntocracies that appear in africa
what's that and these are what's the job
so
gerentocracy is ruled by the old
essentially and so and really it's old
men so what what some societies have
figured out is they put men through a
series of of initiation rights
and at various initiati you have to be
you know you say you might have to be in
your mid to late 30s to get through the
final initiation right which allows you
to finally take a wife so that means you
got this big pool of
20 30-something men who are basically
the warrior cast the warrior class and
eventually they're going to pass through
the right assuming they survive and get
to be old men and then get to be
polygenous but the older men are
basically taking the younger women so as
soon as they're old enough um
to have babies essentially they may get
married off as wives to these older men
and then there's all these young guys
roaming around and this this leads to a
lot of conflict because you need to
accumulate enough bride price
um and
you know
and so there's a lot of rating and
things like that but lots of societies
have had that so places where the elite
you know in the inca empire aztec empire
the elites all maintained large harems
and so um if you look at the early
descriptions from the friars for example
that that showed up in the aztec empire
they talked about how your average
indian uh you know average aztec man had
trouble finding a wife because the
elites had basically taken all the
available women yeah you talk about the
the math problem right
yeah
yeah so this is this idea that when you
know because males and you know humans
tend to have one male and one female uh
you can end up with this
huge you know huge pool of males when
the elite males take all the why all the
all the women as wives
it's not uh
it's not too far from what we're seeing
in the modern world though i'm aware
that it's not because polygeny is
happening all over the place in fact
even though marriage as an institution
and religious rates and stuff are
declining and you can say that
uh contraception and looser
rules and norms around pre-marital sex
and casual relationships and stuff like
that um there is a currently in
asymmetry i think the number of men
reporting no sex between the age of 18
and 30 tripled since 2010 so in the last
10 years that number's tripled you also
have women between the ages of 40 and 45
and the white women are the highest
users of antidepressants at the moment
and that is
sometimes pointed toward women who may
have hit the wall and are
looking at a future which is potentially
childless without a family because they
haven't been able to find a partner that
they feel
attracted to so you have kind of two big
swaths of
uh both genders that
aren't neither of them are particularly
happy with the situation both of them
are single
but you end up even though those women
haven't been tied up
by high status man at the top of the
tree you still get
the sexless underclass of men and
presumably whether it's because women
have been captured by another man or
women haven't hypergamously found
somebody that they're fundamentally
attracted to um
the sexist underclass of men are
probably not fantastic no matter why the
women aren't interested in them
yeah no it's the exact same logic except
here what's happened over the last half
century is that
increasing female choice and female
labor participation female labor market
participation means that it's now an
option for women to not get married and
there's strong evidence that women
prefer males that are high status higher
status than they are and so that means
that women were increasingly willing to
just opt out of the marriage market
entirely um if they can't get a higher
status man which means you got this pool
of men who are who can't get a date
basically and apparently you can see
this uh in
data from dating apps like there's a
relatively small group of men who get
all the interest from the women and
there's a whole bunch of men who never
get a single message
you said that getting married reduces a
man's odds of committing a crime
then when the man got divorced or their
wives passed away the likelihood of
committing a crime increased again after
that
yeah so what the data looks like it
looks like monogamous marriage now
pollution is a separate thing monogamous
marriage domesticates males and probably
even has a hormonal effect of reducing
testosterone reduce testosterone when
you get into get married and then again
when you have children when you have
children and that's in we there's this
happens in lots of animals where you
basically if the male's going to invest
in the offspring you have to lower his
testosterone probably make a few other
adjustments so that he's willing to
protect the nest he's less disagreeable
he's less likely to get into risky
behavior and get into a fight with
someone and then be dead and then the
child doesn't have a father anymore
right right so he's not doing things to
kind of show off and impress the girls
he's doing things like a father would do
where and so what happens when they get
divorced is they have to go back on the
marriage and mating market so t levels
go up
and that means the risks of things like
crime things that would raise your
status you know you want to get some
more money so you can buy a fancy car or
whatever the relevant
yeah whatever your status display is and
uh and yeah so that's that's the
consequence
rolling the clock forward seeing this
imbalance that we have in the sexual
marketplace at the moment and and it
doesn't really feel like either gender
is fantastically happy with it um i'm
not asking you to
come up with like an applied solution
but
what's your prediction if you were to
roll the the clock forward from here
with regards to this imbalance this sort
of gender imbalance that we have in the
sexual marketplace
yeah i mean that's a good question there
could be um a variety of technological
solutions so it could be the way for
example a lot of people find their mates
now on these dating apps it could be the
dating apps could be adjusted so there
would be more chance for
diverse matches
and you know maybe that's going to
happen through competition amongst
different apps
another thing is we don't know what's
going to happen with sex robots
and other kinds of fantasy play based on
technology so that seemed i mean one
place to look is japan where there seems
to be a lot of use of that kind of thing
and there's whole there's a whole class
of males that have opted out of kind of
the dating what's the name for those
guys that live in apartments together
yeah well there's herbivores i don't
know if that's the one you're thinking
of
no well it's a japanese word for it i
can't remember okay yeah i don't know
there's like this
it's not ikigai but it's something like
that um but yeah they call them
don't the chinese call them like
herbivore men or or plant men or
something like that because the chinese
are going through this
we need to make chinese men manly thing
right now right uh they don't want them
anybody to look like k-pop stars so
they've restricted the amount of time
that kids can play video games do you
see this
yeah so oh yeah yeah they're only
allowed to play video games between
eight and nine pm friday saturday sunday
uh they're trying to sort of
re-masculinize chinese men
and they look at the the k-pop stars and
i i'm sure it's called like
plant men or vegetable men or something
her before men might be it and um yeah
they don't want that
yeah it's um
it's a i don't know what it is i i would
like to hope that we could reinvigorate
marriage as an institution um i don't
know whether you saw today but the pope
got in trouble while the pope trended on
twitter for saying that people who get
pets instead of having children and
building a family are basically not
doing their uh
civic duty as a human
uh a human being
which was a
i know i guess a pretty outlandish thing
for the pope to say that
it's like enforced child rearing coming
from the pope someone did make a joke
around the fact that if there's anybody
that shouldn't be encouraging more
children to be around it's the roman
catholic church they
haven't got a fantastic record yeah
they've got to work on their track
record but
yeah i don't know man sex robots thing
is an interesting one um
and it's got no easy i mean there are
some potential solutions but it doesn't
have an obvious one i mean you know
clearly gender equality is not something
we want to relinquish so whatever the
solution it's got to be involved gender
equality
and but that's going to lead to this
problem yeah it's
it's so strange to think back at the
fact that
there is absolutely no reason that women
shouldn't have equal access to
employment to education to the ability
to gain status and prestige and all of
those sorts of things
but bizarrely the fact that
women were held back over the last you
know
post-industrial revolution but pre-what
the last 40 years let's say something
like that 30 years um that made it
easier for women to find a relationship
with a man that they were fundamentally
attracted to because they weren't
competing themselves out of the overall
dominance hierarchy by rising up it it's
it's so weird that dynamics so
fascinating and
sort of
stark and brutal as well right right and
then the tricky part is if you're a
woman the higher you go up the status
hierarchy the the less attractive most
men get right
because you only like men that are you
know at least you're equal right really
like higher but but equals probably okay
lower that just seems lame well dude
think about how
brutal it is that you can spend a decade
building up your career or getting a phd
or doing a startup or whatever is some
super high performing woman
and then you think right i
would also like to have a family let's
look at the potential dating pool that i
have there's like three guys there's
three guys out of seven billion people
that are above and across from where you
are what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace